oh man
is that what y'all call a stretch big
now y'all thought that was new
oh no lambie was doing that way back in
the day
[Music]
rebound to kevin lowe
and he turns and scores rebound love
cavaliers come the other way great
outlet left unbelievable outlet there by
love
love the offensive rebound back up backs
it in
the thing i love about kevin love is
when i first saw him at ucla he was
known for his great outlet passes kevin
love is also known for his ability to
shoot the three long range so his
rebounding his long-range shooting his
defense his toughness that's what kevin
love is known for let me tell you about
another guy before kevin love who was
just like kevin love his name is bill
lambir
makes a fine block from behind can they
tie sally
got it he tipped it in mid left for
ewing a step in front and a steal by
lambeau
[Applause]
[Music]
and i know what you're going to say
you're going to be like oh bill lambert
you know he hit people he was dirty blah
blah blah you know all them lies you've
been told but let me tell you about the
truth about bill lambert 13 years bill
lambert missed nine games no load
management no my back hurt no i can't
play every single night my teammate was
dependable reliable showed up every
night to play with lambeau led the
league in rebounding great outlet passer
shoot it run dunk you name it if we
don't have bill lambie on our team the
detroit pistons we never win the
championship
nice shot he's the best outside shooting
big man in the game fires a three
enhancer
lock
pick and roll pick and pop that was
lambeau and i he would tell robert
parish you got to come out here and give
me chiefs i'm 17 feet away from the
basket wow
oh man is that what y'all call a stretch
big now y'all thought that was new
oh no lambie was doing that way back in
the day
in the era where the centers and the
power forwards
had to post up to be effective
bill lambert was one of the few who
changed the game and moved the five and
the four out to the perimeter for jump
shots by the way bill lambie was heavily
criticized because he wasn't a post-up
player now you have a whole league of
bigs playing like bill lambert and not
necessarily posting up so who was right
[Applause]
orchestrator perhaps of the biggest
turnaround in professional sports
history it is one thing to win a title
one title it's hard to do but they have
set a standard of excellence in this
league bill lambert has won in the wnba
as a coach has won in the nba as a
player i don't think there has been a
more impactful wnba coach than bill
lambert what he did in detroit than what
he did for the new york liberty and then
what he just did for las vegas aces bill
lambert for all his work in his journey
through basketball deserves to be in the
hall of fame
nice fake
he hits
tatum couldn't get it to go gets the
rebound and scores dishes to land their
left corner he buries it
kevin love shooting at three rebounding
outline being a great teammate setting
screens wow what a concept picking and
popping kevin love bill lambiere go look
it up you'll see the similarity
[Music]
[Applause]